[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
quem está tocando a reggina sua obra que
a minha mãe ea mãe pianista ea música
também influência muito grande na minha
vida desde sempre
o estúdio dela ficava embaixo da minha e
do meu quarto e eu brinquei namorei
estudei durante os primeiros 20 anos da
minha vida escutando piano e ela mas
supersticiosa de história da música a
gente conversava muito sobre deve-se sob
chuva sobre o bar sobre villa-lobos
mas ela nunca falou do bartolomeo
cristófori bartolomeu que só para ver o
cara que inventou o piano antes do piano
tinha um negócio chamada cravo que o
mecanismo é uma cunha feita da ponta da
asa de um avião que buscava uma corda um
instrumento frágil de madeira e ele
entendeu que a sociedade naquela época
queria fazer uma mudança grande e tem
mais interpretação essa infração sabe de
coisas mais altas e mais baixas mais
fortes e mais pianos inventou forte
piano ou que ano forte para fazer o
atendimento a essa tecnologia
maravilhosa que é o martelo para quem
não sabe o que não tem vários martelos e
uma base de metal para assegurar às
cordas mas fora isso fez com que a
música mudar se no mundo mas ninguém
nunca me falou do bartolomeu e não falou
porque a tecnologia inventor é
importante mas mais importante que a
tecnologia o inventor é a maneira como a
gente aproveita e diz e nina e utiliza o
impacto o mundo com a tecnologia já está
no momento de um fetiche gigantesco pela
tecnologia
a própria definição as últimas
tecnologias do que foi inventado nos
últimos nove ou dez anos
ninguém consegue explicar aqui como é
que o teu carro quando você liga o rádio
aparece música como é que alguém fala
numa rádio depois vai para uma máquina
vai para a antena vem pelo ar no teu
carro em movimento e você vê que tem uma
caixa de som com conexões um só que esse
fetiche não tinha a minha mãe mesmo
quando saiu de 34 falou assim filho a
gente precisa entender um pouquinho como
é que funciona não consigo escutar você
sabia
como é que a fita cassete tocava no
cabeçote não mas o fetiche não era
grande a gente tá um momento onde a
gente tem os que adoram ir que os
rodeiam a tecnologia e parece que tem
gente que torce e vai contra esse
godzilla turbinado com computação
quântica que vai invadir e destruir
salvar a humanidade
isso não vem de agora em 1997 o kasparov
perdeu por exemplo o computador da ibm
foi um jogo apertado 3 e 6 4 e meio mas
ele perdeu tem uma coisa engraçada até
que no meio da jogada no meio do jogo
tem uma jogada tão absurda que ele achou
que tava roubando e descobriu depois que
era um bug do sistema um paulo
mas ele perdeu a sociedade como
rendimento
o the new york times escreve na plena
linha ali uma mudança brutal o
computador de blu destronou a humanidade
que ninguém conta que alguns anos depois
em 2004 ele fez um outro jogo uma
competição que podia tudo podia máquina
podia computador por uma mistura dos
dois
e quem ganhou foi um grupo de amadores
com computadores locais
quem eu fui espécie humana de utilizou
lobo frontal aos presentes que a
evolução nos deu e usou a tecnologia
como uma ferramenta usa a tecnologia
como uma forma de resolver um problema
foi a vitória da criatividade do
amadorismo
por isso eu gosto muito da metáfora que
o thomas friedman faz neste momento de
inteligência aumentada onde o corpo ea
pata espera do cavalo é a força ea
velocidade da tecnologia mas o douro céu
ea cabeça é a mente ea alma humana e
essa mistura que faz esse momento que a
gente está vivendo o seu único
não estou negando a lei de muro alto
obrigando o crescimento exponencial da
tecnologia do mundo efetivamente a
mudança está muito mais rápido mas se a
mudança muito mais rápido acontecem duas
coisas a primeira é a gente tem que
celebrar os humanos estão por trás para
permitir essa mudança mais rápida ea
segunda a gente tem que aprender melhor
o aprendizado essa é a grande ferramenta
pra gente conviver melhor nosso ser
anjo eu acho que em algumas definições
de aprendizado que a gente entender
primeiramente acho que aprender a
receber conteúdo receber conteúdo lê
youtube livro e aprendizado é diferente
aquisição de conteúdo mas é muito
difícil porque pra gente foi durante
muito tempo ensinado que era assim essa
menina linda que o livro é minha filha
um dos meus três filhos e ao livro
quando tinha cinco anos ela perguntou
pra mim assim pai que é o primeiro ano e
com uma carinha eu gravar meu primeiro
ano porque está perguntando por que você
tá brava porque para tal infantil 5
voltei ao filho é um jeito de contar a
escola e vai até quando encerrou né
quem acabou estudo aqui daí filho
pequeno a resposta curta básico vai até
o 9º ano
tá bom depois da faculdade né quem não
filha
depois tem mais três anos de ensino
médio a faculdade que nenhuma mãe e
minha esposa mudou de carreira estava na
segunda pós graduação da ufs a conta 5 +
9 14 + 3 17 + 4 21 mais quatro são 25
anos talvez 70% da nossa idade adulta
até os 30 por cento acordado estudando
acham que aprender é receber conteúdo e
como a gente cresce muito mas sabe tem
muito mais conteúdo a gente não consegue
produzir e acha que está prendendo a
atenção de aprendizado é essa
explicitação do conhecimento por meio de
uma performance melhorada essa frase
louca quer dizer que aprender e colocar
para fora o que a gente faz e fazendo
melhor serve patrick ou serve pra crochê
serve para a inteligência artificial
alguém alguém cozinha que não levanta a
mão quem cozinha
quem faz risoto é mais um que tem gente
que não cozinha faz risoto é
interessante
mas imagina que é é uma mágica
imagina que você porque você faz isso
vai fazer risoto de mais um curso no
ipad maravilhoso esse curso é tão legal
você pega o arroz arbóreo do mapa da
itália vota na panela de ritual se fica
rodando arroz pra soltar o amigo virtual
enquanto uma pessoa está dizendo olha e
você ganha um certificado de roteiro na
itália
isso nunca faz o risoto se aprendeu a
não aprendeu porque o homem que a gente
está num momento de experiência aumento
de fazer e aprendizado tem a ver com
fazer
aliás o certificado já acho uma loucura
entregar o certificado no final do curso
é quem faz um curso emagrecimento dois
dizem ao gol de magrão é aprender a
interagir tem a ver com fazer
tem um cara muito legal chamado foi
nasce o pouso pesquisador que há 30 anos
falou 'tá vendo uma nova sociedade a
mudança é tão grande que está havendo
uma nova espécie chamada ou mude sainz
disse simms homo sapiens é o que sabe
como dizem o que aprendi
o revised homo sapiens que a gente tem
aqui é uma versão desenvolvida há algum
tempo que é feita para quem tem mais de
30 anos não mais que 30 anos com 30 anos
seu neto já nasceu e você está roubando
a comida dele então vai embora e se
organize
quando a gente coloca longevidade e
crescimento exponencial de informação
a gente vai ter que mudar e vai ter que
quebrar os 25 anos e aprendeu ao longo
da vida o que é bacana que olhar talvez
pra voarmos sap subiram como disse é uma
olhada do antropólogo imagina uma
proposta quando chega numa ilha ela não
chega ainda usando odiando que ela tá
vendo ela tinha o olhar de admiração ao
chão molhado sem julgamento e talvez
seja isso olhar para o mundo que a gente
precisa e mais contra o pólo controlo
curioso curiosidade como vocês podem ver
aqui é uma das habilidades do século 21
que a o fórum econômico mundial sugere
tá na direita que curiosidade realmente
é um chamariz do aprendizado e é
desenvolvido aqui eu acho uma loucura
por causa da habilidade do século 21
para os jovens porque eles devem ter
lido como eu li
que eles estão trabalhando estão
aprendendo coisas na escola de
profissões que não existem ainda né
a gente não tá alguém não vai trabalhar
daqui a 20 anos também então esse
processo é mais amplo do que formar
jovens é formar uma sociedade que vê
mais 50 60 anos trabalhando que também
não têm as competências
por isso a solução uma delas é life
lugano eo aprendizado ao longo da vida
apesar da longa vida a um ponto que a
unesco levanta já há 30 anos com um
problema gigantesco a gente vai ter uma
nova classe de letrados não vai dar para
fazer escolas e formar professores na
velocidade que a gente precisa a gente
ia dar o aprendizado na mão das pessoas
e reconhecer isso de uma maneira
importante por isso que eu acho que o
futurismo é uma coisa super importante o
mundo precisa cada vez mais futuristas
gente que pensa no futuro desejável
influencia o presente pra gente chegar
até lá mas eu sou o presente se existe
alguém que sabe que já têm o futuro aí
que está atingindo um monte de gente mas
está deixando de atingir um muito maior
no futuro que está distribuído mesmo o
futurista é alguém que não reconhece o
privilégio de estar aqui hoje de viajar
o mundo de ler disse interessado está
acontecendo no mundo e tem uma posição
especial para observar esse mundo em
mudança
um presente esta é alguém que não se
conforma em ter um grupo pequeno
discutindo o que vai acontecer no mundo
e que discutir de maneira incestuosa
se o carro autônomo em 2020 e 2022 o
colégio vai ter a pílula com o nano
robôs para a gente saber o que está
acontecendo
a discussão tem que sair desse grupo o
futurista acima de tudo alguém que
trabalha com o princípio da abundância
trabalha com o princípio da empatia
é alguém que sabe que quanto mais
pessoas tiverem contato com a tecnologia
melhora ao mundo essa minha mãe tocando
de novo
hoje mãe eu falei você tem essa música
digital e ela não tinha mas ela mandou
direto ela falou filho eu gravei no
mistério do meu telefone e acho que
serve pra você e diz que a gente precisa
mais gente sabendo usar a tecnologia
como uma ferramenta e conseguiu empatar
o mundo fundo ser presente esta é a
crença que quanto mais gente tiver
contato com tecnologia melhor ao mundo
precisam ter os artistas e compositores
que não vão saber tocar os novos
instrumentos de um lado pela nova
tecnologia eo mundo vai ter menos arte -
música eu acho que o mundo sem arte
musical mundo muito chato pois meu
convite é que sejamos todos mais
presentes
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i